so today i'm going to talk about
functional data structures in a language
called julia
and i'm using julia for code samples and
that's where i actually did the work but
i
hope that these ideas are more general
than julia and that if you wanted to you
could take them
and and implement something like this in
another language
um so it's worth talking first about
julia the language before we actually
get started with the data structures
themselves
so julia has matlab-like syntax and it's
poised as a language for technical
computing but i think it's a lot more
general than that
um julia is a dynamic language but it's
also fast and has a nice chit compiler
and julia also has types now the type
theory patents among us would want me to
point out that what julia has are run
time type tags not compile time types
and that julia types are used for
performance and expressiveness
as opposed to safety or correctness as
you'd see in a language like haskell
the primary unit of abstraction in julia
is called the generic function
a generic function is a first class
function that dispatches to a particular
implementation based on the types of all
of its arguments
and you use these pervasively throughout
julia for extending
your own data types to built-in
functionality in the language
so let's talk about generic functions
really quick and what you can do first
we're going to define
a data type this is an abstract binary
tree
it has a concrete type which is a node
that it's immutable means that once i
create these
fields they cannot change i can say my
new node.data equals something else once
i have it it's this immutable value
so node is a binary tree it has some
data associated with it
it also has a left and a right tree that
has to be a binary tree
so we have two concrete types of binary
tree which means that the left and right
field of node
are either going to be another node or a
leaf or at the bottom of the tree
so a leaf just has some data associated
with it we can create a new one of these
binary trees like this
something that might be useful is asking
is the number three in my binary tree
so in julia this syntax three in some
binary tree
parses to something like this so i have
base dot
n bass.n is a generic function in
julia's core library
and it's going to pass in the item that
we're looking for as the first argument
and then the tree that we're searching
that we're searching in as the second
argument
so if we want to implement in for our
binary tree we can do it like this
here we're saying that if the first
argument is some data and the second
argument is one of our leaves
then we see if that data is contained in
the leaf by asking if that data is equal
to that leafs data
a recursive case is the case of a node
so we first say
is this data that node's data if it
isn't then is it in the left side of the
tree or is it in the right side of the
tree
and once we have this we can kind of
partake in this built-in syntax and
julia so this is kind of how we use
generic functions
to extend our own data types to the
syntax of the language
and we have this kind of nice extension
now let's talk a little bit about
functional programming and functional
data structures
i think a precise definition of
functional programming is a little bit
elusive and people like to debate it so
i'm going to totally punt on it
instead just say that functional
programming encourages programming with
immutable values
not mutable objects the data structures
of a functional language should support
this
when you change one of them it shouldn't
actually mutate it it should instead
return a new value
and leave the old one unmodified this
means that they're persistent old
versions stay around the data structures
should support multiple versions of the
same fundamental thing
they should also be fast and they should
guarantee the same or roughly the same
kind of computational complexity
characteristics of their mutable
counterparts
julia has some not functional data
structures already built in we're just
going to move through
a few of them really quickly so i can
create a new vector like this and i can
index into it
something interesting here is that
notice that a of one returns one
it doesn't return two that's because
julia is indexed from one
this isn't much of a big deal but it
will impact some of the code that we
write a little bit later
i can push a new element into our vector
and then notice when i query the length
it's actually increased it's mutated so
these are just arrays or lists like
you'd see in any you know
regular kind of imperative language
julia also supports maps which it calls
dicts
and you can create them as you might
expect you can add new elements to it as
you might expect so this is
pretty standard julia also has sets
i can create a set of the characters a b
and c this ellipsis
is the splat operator and is going to
treat the string as
a sequence of three characters and kind
of expand it out into the arguments to
the set constructor
i can push another character into it and
i can ask if d is in alpha and of course
it is
now notice that here i use push bang
this is the julia idiom for some kind of
collection mutating operation now what i
want
is something that's persistent so we're
going to get pretty close to by the end
of this talk is the ability to create
like a persistent vector i should be
able to query it the same way
but when i push something into it
instead of mutating the original one i
should simply get back a new one and if
i ask the length of the original a
notice that it's still 5.
i should also be able to do the same
with maps i should be able to associate
a new key value pair onto an existing
hash map and i should get back a new one
but if i look in the previous hash map
for the key suraban
i don't get to know that he's not quite
as brave as sir lancelot
and the same thing with sets so this is
all pretty standard this is
what you might expect if you were doing
functional programming but in case you
haven't done a lot of it this is what we
expect these operations to do kind of
once we're through with this
so let's do a quick simple example of an
easily
kind of persistent data structure people
talk about a certain class of problems
as being embarrassingly parallel
i think that the linked list is
embarrassingly persistent
so here we have a linked list x that
points to some tail
we don't care what the tail is but we
might want a new linked list y
which is the result of considering some
element onto x
and then we might say well i actually
want a list z and z is the result of
considering some element onto the rest
of x
here we can see that all three of these
lists are sharing
structure and this is really useful we
actually kind of want this property in
our
persistent and functional data
structures
one for space efficiency because that
means that that when i create a new
version i don't have to
uh hold in memory two copies of the same
thing
um but also for computational efficiency
i don't wanna have to copy every single
element over to my new structure just
because it's immutable that would be
pretty awful
so phil bagwell in i think 2000
talked about two different data
structures the array map tri and the
hash array map tri
rich hickey when creating closure
adapted these data structures
and created something called a bitmap
vector try which is what supports
closure's kind of persistent collections
i think it's also been used in scala
for for scala's i think
collections.immutable namespace
now the bitmap bitmap vector try is a
try
a try means that it's a tree where the
data is in the leaves
and the nodes going down to the leaves
represent a path
to a certain piece of data a kind of
common example of this is a prefix tree
used for string lookup
so at the top you might have single
characters and as you get further down
you might have string prefixes and this
could be used for something like
autocomplete we're going to be looking
at tries that work on the bitwise level
though because what we want is a try
that represents some kind of random
access array-like structure
so the nodes are going to take a peek at
certain bits
of the index and it's going to lead us
down to the actual element
so let's talk about a persistent vector
this is where we're really going to get
into the data structures and the goal
here
is to focus more on the data structures
at a high level and while i will show
some code what i really want
is for people to understand how these
data structures might actually be
implemented
so they could be implemented in other
languages as well
so persistent vector is an array and
it's array of a certain
fixed number of elements
and this is just a mutable array like
you'd expect in some kind of imperative
language
each one of the elements of this array
are a bunch more arrays that are also of
the same size
and they also contain the same types of
arrays that are of the same size
and the very bottom we actually get real
data so here
four levels deep we actually have the
actual indices
uh in this case this might be the data
but it happens to be the indices when
if we were indexing into this vector but
this is the high level representation
notice also that this thing is actually
dense so everything on the left-hand
side would be filled in
and we can just pretend that everything
is filled in but obviously that'll be
too many arrows
so you know useful or first we can talk
about i guess the actual data
representation so we can look at some
more julia code
so we're going to have an abstract
bitmap try and we're going to have an
array node
an array node has a array an internal
array which is a vector of
bitmap tries and it also has the shift
value which we'll talk about later
and then it has a length and a max
length the length isn't just
its length because all of them are going
to be eventually length 4 in the case of
this example
it's actually going to be the length
that represents the number of elements
that are in its
in its leaves all the way down i mean
the max length is the total size
that it can grow to before it needs to
do something and we'll look at what that
thing is
then we have an array leaf which just
has this internal vector
so let's talk about how we actually
access something so let's pretend
that we already have this pre-built
thing and we want to access index 106.
so the key insight here is that we can
look at 106 as a binary representation
and let's pretend that we're in some
world with 8-bit integers
so each level of the try is going to
take a peek
at a certain sequence or a certain view
of this index
at the very top we're going to look at
the
top two bits then we're going to look at
the middle left bits
the middle right bits and the bottom
bits so this is really interesting
notice
that this series of bits corresponds to
basically how to index down into the try
so the very top we need to look at index
one then index two index two index
two and that corresponds with the actual
binary
the math of this isn't particularly
difficult either
at the top we do a shift right of 6 and
then we mask
with or we do a bitwise and with 3 and
that's to kind of mask off the top bits
so all we have to do is just change the
number of
bits that we shift to the right and we
get down to our answer 106.
so let's define these bitwise operations
we'll have a couple helper functions
shift value so the shift value for an
array node is that shift field so the
the actual nodes themselves are going to
keep track of how far
an index has to shift for them to look
at the correct bits
an array leaf always looks at the bottom
bit so it shifts by zero
then we can write our mask function so
remember that julia's index from one
and this bitmap only works out if we are
considering indices from zero so the
kind of easy solution to this
is just to quickly decrement i before we
do the math so this is the same math
that we saw before where we have some
index
we're going to shift it to the right by
the shift value of that particular
tree that we're looking at and then
we're going to do a bitwise and with
three to mask off the top bits
the reason also that we're looking at at
two bits and we're doing and with three
is because
it takes two bits to represent four
pieces of information and our tries are
all
each node is has an array of length four
and then we increment the view
um back up so that we're back kind of
into into julia index from one land
so now we can implement git index and
what this will allow us to do is
actually use
the bracket syntax for indexing into
something and now this is quite simple
once we have this mask function
if we're in a leaf the way that we get
the index is just by indexing into the
internal array
the result of masking the correct
view so this is really simple there's a
recursive case if we're in a node
we have to mask the node index correctly
but then we also make a recursive
call notice that there's this extra
bracket of i and that's because
when we access an element from the array
node's internal array
we're going to get back another bitmap
try and we want to continue down until
we get to the very bottom and actually
access an element
now let's think about associating a new
element with an index that already
exists
in one of these in one of these bitmap
vectors
so the idea here remember is that now
we're updating something that already
exists but we can't change it because we
don't want to mutate anything
we need this previous version to be
available so what we're going to do
is as we navigate down to the element
we're going to
copy just the path that it takes to get
down to it
so here i can copy that top node but
notice that it's sharing the structure
on the left right and middle right side
of this new node so we only need to copy
the elements on the path
and we continue this process down until
we get to the very bottom where here
i've replaced
106 with foo now this is really
interesting
this is a structure that can contain 256
elements in order to update one and keep
it immutable we've only had to copy 16
things
that's pretty fast
also a quick thing functional data
structures are made with lots of errors
so this is a pretty simple thing to
actually code if we're
going to write our associate function
for a leaf
all we do is we copy the internal array
so this
bracket colon operation is like python
slice operations just a way of copying
copying an array and getting a new one
back then in this new array that no one
else has access to we can actually do
the mutating thing
so we just set the element in the proper
thing in the proper slot
and then we create a new array leaf with
that new array and we return it
we have a slightly more complicated
recursive case where we have an array
node
um so now what we need to do we do the
same copying but notice that we have a
recursive call on this on the third line
of the function
where instead of just immediately adding
the element we have to
associate the element with the child and
then add that child into our new
internal array
and then we create a new similar array
node we don't have to update anything so
we use the previous nodes attributes to
do that
so now the thing that we want to do is
now assuming that something is already
constructed
we can get an index from it and we can
update an index but we have no way of
growing this thing
so we need push we need a way of
actually increasing the size
of our of our persistent vector
but push is a little bit more
complicated there are a few different
cases that we have to consider when
we're actually growing the thing
so if we're trying to push into an array
leaf we have to consider whether or not
it's full
or not trying to push into an array node
we have to consider whether it's last
child has room so that we could append
to the last child
whether the last child is full in which
case we need to create a new last child
or whether the array node itself is full
in which case we have to create a new
containing array node
so we'll go through each of those cases
here so here
we're going to push 2 onto a vector that
is not full
this is really easy we just copy we just
do a copy
and we add 2n and so this is a pretty
simple case but what if we've
we have a full array leaf and we want to
add 4 into it
in this case we construct a new array
node
the first element of which points to
that previous leaf and the second
element of which points to a new child
that contains four so whereas in this
previous example we did have to do some
copying here copying is is
actually there's no copying really
that's happening and we're just
constructing new things
that can share the structure of that
previous thing and these are just one of
the benefits that you get where
everything is immutable
now if we want to push 5 onto this new
array node that we've constructed
well in this case our right most child
still has room
so we can just add it into that right
most child the way we do that
is by again creating a new top level and
copying the path down and adding five
then
now assuming we have eight again we just
do kind of the same thing where now our
right most child was full so we need to
construct a new child and add it in
there
and this is similar to the case where
our leaf was full
if our node is full then we just
construct a new parent
that points down to a final child
so this is kind of important we won't go
into the actual code of this because
there's quite a lot there's a lot of
cases to handle
but it's pretty simple really what you
need to do is nodes need to know how to
construct children
they need to know how to construct
parents and then they just look at
themselves and their children to
determine whether or not an element
being associated in
can just go directly in or whether they
need to do some kind of promotion or
demotion
so the astute among you might notice
that i never
actually defined a persistent vector
type i held off on this and just defined
a
bitmap try because the persistent vector
is going to implement an optimization
so the persistent vector has three
attributes it has an internal tri
which is a bitmap try and then it has a
tail which is a vector
and then it can it also stores its
length so we have constant access to
that
so the question though is what is this
tail so
in our examples we appended our actual
data directly to the try
but what if instead we appended full
vectors so instead of appending data we
appended
length four vectors so all of the leaves
contained length four vectors
this would be really interesting then
what we would have is we would have
fast access to the tail up at the top
with our persistent vector and one of
the most common things you do when
you're constructing large arrays is
appending to the back
which also means that we and basically
what that means is that if our
vectors are length four then we only
have to touch the try one every
one out of four appends otherwise we can
just add to this tail we do this copying
that's very fast and very easy for us to
access
so this is really nice we only update
the try when the tail is full
and this would actually require some
other changes to the code because
when you got the index or when you when
you asked the try for the element index
106
what you would get back is actually
another vector and so you would need
to make sure that your try leaves you
some bits such that you can look in that
final vector and get the element that
you're looking for
but this is a optimization that has a
pretty significant impact on your
ability to
add elements to the back of a persistent
vector to the point where
it's it's something on the order of only
five times slower than
doing a uh like push bang onto a regular
array it's quite fast
now we also don't really use length four
internal vectors in an actual
implementation of this
uh phil bagwell has this graph in in one
of his papers
um basically when you're increasing the
size of the nodes or of these internal
arrays there's a trade-off between
indexing speed and update speed so when
the arrays are small
update is slightly faster because you
don't have to copy as many elements when
you're
copying down the path but indexing is
slower because we have more steps that
you have to go down when you're trying
to
get an element and it just turns out
that 32
tends to be a pretty good balance and
this graph it looks like 16 might
actually be a bit better but i didn't do
any testing i just used 32.
there's some further reading if you're
interested in persistent vectors
so um in 2011 there's another paper that
came out
rrb trees efficient immutable vectors
bagwell saw
some of the work that was done that
adapted some of his older data
structures to newer functional languages
and thought well
we could do even a little bit better
than this one thing that's a bit of a
bummer
with with this adaptation is that
concatenation is still
order in so you have these two trees and
you want to concatenate them together
the way that you do it is you just
pull all of the elements from one tree
into the other one
so we created this structure rrb trees
which stands for relaxed
radix balance trees and these relax
the length of the vectors and have a
balancing operation that allows you to
get
login order login concatenation time
this is something that i haven't looked
into enough yet to be able to describe
in any more detail than i just did
but it's definitely a further place to
go that could give you even better
characteristics there's a small
trade-off with
indexing and update speed but i also
think that there's a way
there's an implementation enclosure that
i think avoids this trade-off until
you've actually done the concatenation
so it it delays kind of promotion to
this relaxed radix balanced
version until you've actually done the
concatenation so in practice it's not
much of an issue
so now let's talk about hash maps so we
kind of have our first data structure
out of the way and we've seen how we can
use a bitmap vector try
to construct something that is immutable
and also is array-like
so how do you normally construct a hash
table well hash tables are built on
array-like things that gives us some
indication that we might be able to use
this same fundamental data structure to
create our hash map
mutable hash maps usually common
implementations start at a fixed size
say eight
you insert elements based on some hash
and you look at maybe the bottom bits
so if we have a size 8 we'd look at the
bottom three bits and we when we hash
values and we'd insert them in there
but you have to deal with collisions
because eventually
if you have you know eight elements it's
likely that you've run into some
collisions at that point so what you
commonly do is you resize the table when
you're roughly two-thirds full to avoid
lots of these collisions
and this resize operation has some cost
but it's amortized over the
the kind of lifespan of the of the data
structure
and the resize might be like four times
when you're kind of at small sizes it
might start doubling once you get a
little bit larger
our persistent hash map is going to also
have to handle collisions but we're
going to do it in a way that avoids
resizing altogether
and we're just going to kind of get
immediately started with this data
structure i'm just looking at how we add
new elements to it so let's pretend
that we're on a leaf with our persistent
hash map this is again
going to be another try except that
we're not really going to have a concept
of nodes and leaves
every single every single node has the
ability to contain
actual data or to contain pointers to
further tries
and so here we have the very top so it's
going to grow in a different way from
the persistent vector here we're at the
very top and we've inserted two keys i'm
just kind of ignoring the values at this
point
but again because we're length four
we're only looking at the bottom two
bits
so we have sir robin inserted into
index one because those are his bottom
two bits in cerbedavir is inserted into
index two
now let's say that sir lancelot comes
along and he wants to partake in this
hashing experience so we're gonna insert
sir lancelot but we have a collision
so what we're gonna do is we're simply
going to copy
the this kind of root um and then we're
going to construct a subtry
and so whereas uh index two previously
pointed to
betavir now it's going to point to
another try and we're going to use
you know the next set of bits to index
sir lancelot and sir bedavir into this
previous try so now we've avoided the
collision
and if we want to say update to robin's
value
then we can do that just as well all we
have to do is we copy
the the that top level structure we can
share
um that that try that we've already
created that contains or lancelot and
sir bedavir but now we have this updated
version and in all of these
slides where we have some element in the
background all of those pointers are
still intact nothing has actually been
changed
so we do still have an immutable
structure
the question that we want to ask though
or what about these
it's normally an immutable hash table
you have these extra slots
they're basically just empty slots but
they're taking up memory and they're
there because you're going to resize
much larger than the data you actually
have such that you can avoid lots of
collisions
we actually have a kind of a nice thing
that we can do with a persistent hash
map where we can avoid this all together
so what we're going to do is we're going
to add a number to each one of these
nodes
and this number is going to be the
number of bits that it
that is its size basically so because
this particular node
on the left has four slots we need four
bits
we're going to turn on the bits that
correspond to entries
that have been inserted into the hash
map so
the bit on the far right is going to be
index 0 and then 1 2
3. so in this case 1 and 2 are on so
the binary is is 0 1 1 0. we're going to
do the same thing for this one over here
so now we have this bitmap that
corresponds to
entries that have been inserted into our
hash table now this might not be obvious
but what this allows us to do
is totally collapse our structure and
eliminate
empty spaces altogether so let's see how
that actually works
let's say that i want to access sir
better beer so i
i hash that key and i get this this
you know binary number on the right hand
side
now i want to be able to use the same
kind of search strategy that we used
with the persistent vector
to access to kind of navigate down the
try and and ultimately get to that key
value pair
but unfortunately notice on the right
hand side i've highlighted one zero
which is two
but i actually need to be indexing into
one because we've collapsed we've lost
some indices
so let's look so now what i've done is
i've copied over the bitmap from the
left hand side
and we can first ask does this
try have the index that we're looking
for and
we do that because each each one of the
on bits corresponds to some index that
has something inserted into it
so it turns out that if we look at the
you know 0 1
2 bit it's on which means that we do
actually have that index
what we can then do is mask off all of
the bits at that index
and above and then do a bit count so bit
count
is an operation that exists on most
modern architectures
which is a very fast counting of the
bits that are on
in some sort of integer so here
we get the true index it just turns out
that this trick always works when you
have everything set up this way
we mask off the top bits and then we do
a bit count to figure out the actual
offset and the true index
so now we can index and move on to the
next thing and just to show that it
works here
we have the same kind of situation where
we're looking at two it happens to be on
we mask off the top bits we do a bit
count and we can access cerbetavir
so there's a couple different types that
we need to create for this
this particular implementation we're
going to have a immutable hash map entry
and then we're going to hold on to the
hash so that we don't have to recompute
it later we'll just store it
and then it has some key and some value
then we're going to have a sparse bitmap
tree
and even though it has it is actually
compact sparse
is to indicate that we have some bitmap
and that in reality only some of the
indices
in the internal array are on
so we can create a sparse array node
this vector
contains possibly two types it contains
either more sparse bitmap tries which in
this case just happens to be more sparse
array nodes
or it can train contains hash map
entries then we have the same attributes
that we saw
on the regular array node for the
persistent vector except we have an
addition
of a bitmap which is an integer that
we're going to use
to we're going to use to basically keep
track of what entries have been inserted
then we define shift val because we've
kind of have this contract that all
bitmap tries
should have some shift value so that we
can use the same mask function
to figure out what kind of section of
bits we should be looking at at each
point
now we can define we can do all of the
bit math that we basically wanted to do
before
so if we find the the way that we can
find the bit position
is by finding the two bits that we're
looking for or
i mean in this case it happens to be two
bits but finding the bits that we're
actually interested in
subtracting one so if we're interested
if we if we happen to find
bits that represented like like three
for instance um
uh we want to subtract
wow this complicated stuff um so any
anyways
um so so we we we get this mask we
subtract one and we shift a one up and
the goal here is basically we want a
number which
is um uh something that is a multiple of
two
basically and it's going to represent
the single bit which is the position
in the bitmap we can then ask if it has
if this index is on
by doing an and with that bit position
so we have this bitmap if we do an and
with that bit position
it's only going to be something non-zero
in the case
that in the case that that bit was also
on
in the bitmap then we can determine the
slot
by uh basically doing the same thing
where in this case we're doing the bit
position -1 so if our bit position
happened to be 32
what we would get is 31 which would mask
off the bottom right bits
and then we can count all of those ones
and then increment again because we're
in julia index from one land
so this this is the kind of bitmap that
we need to do in order to
use this kind of modified version of the
vector try
so there are some things that we haven't
shown here one is deletions
deletions are actually pretty simple
with a persistent hash map
deletions are more complicated in a
mutable version because usually you have
you have to somehow indicate that the
way that that mutable versions usually
hand collisions
handle collisions are that um if you
go to a spot and it's full you just look
at a next series of bits and then jump
to another slot
when you do a kind of a git index you
first go to that slot and say hey this
isn't what i'm looking for i need to go
to the next slot that it would be at
which means that if you delete something
you can't just remove it entirely
because then when you go back and
there's nothing there you say oh this
key isn't there
so i'm just going to give up with the
persistent variant we never
actually do this jumping around so you
can just delete things and it's pretty
trivial
you also do need to handle true hash
collision so this is the case where two
different values actually do hash to the
exact same thing
this is pretty unlikely i mean in julia
if you have a good hash function and
you're getting back some kind of 64-bit
engineer it's pretty unlikely that
you're going to get true hash collisions
but a simple way of handling this would
be to have another node type that exists
in your hash map it might be a collision
node and if you actually if you ever get
down to a collision node you have to do
the kind of slower key comparison
you can't just do a really fast hash
comparison
so now let's talk about persistent set
this was a bit of a lie
i said i was going to talk about three
data structures today but
you just kind of wrap the map right a
persistent set is really just a hash map
where the values
are nil so this is really useful
and then you just kind of implement all
the regular set operations but in this
case you basically get this third data
structure for free
just by creating this efficient variant
of the hashmap that happens to be
persistent
let's talk a little bit about
performance lookups are very fast
lookups are log 32 of n when
n is like 4 billion that happens to be 6
so we're just going to say that
that it's basically constant time this
happens to do with the very large
branching factor of the try
if you think about what you're actually
doing to access an index let's say you
have like
you know you have seven layers of depth
you're doing like 14 bit operations and
seven pointer d references
so these are these are really fast
things
uh updates are a little bit slower
because you you actually have to do some
copying
but if you do have say a full persistent
vector that has billions of elements in
it you're still at max
only only copying like a couple hundred
elements
and that's a pretty small price to pay
to have immutability in such a large
structure
there's some interesting i think
conclusions that we can draw from this
julia happens to be a really good
language for
creating these kinds of structures even
though
it doesn't have a static type system its
type system is pretty expressive
and generic functions make it very easy
to extend
new data types to the existing language
you also get a huge amount from this one
fundamental data structure
all we really had to do was kind of
understand this bit vector try
and then with a pretty small
modification we were able to extend it
to a hash map
and we get just kind of a lot just for
understanding this one thing
it's also i think worthwhile thinking
about creating functional abstractions
in a mutable world
julia isn't a language that comes with
these things by default
it's a language for which they're pretty
easily provided
and i think it's worth exploring
different ways to look at existing
languages and find ways of extending
them
maybe in ways that they weren't intended
so this
this is kind of a interesting example of
this where lots of our
implementation had to do with mutation
we're using these underlying mutable
things
to create a nice functional abstraction
now i have a more complete
implementation of these
at zakalon functionalcollections.jl
it's still a bit of a work in progress
but but it has quite a bit more if
you're interested in more code you can
see it there
that's it i'm zach alon i work at hacker
school in new york
and i appreciate you taking the time to
listen to me